what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation I am about to show you guys my reaction
first time watching for the movie Moana spoiler
alert uh wow what an incredibly moving film
before I show you guys that couple things
leave a like you know you know how much I
love when you leave a like and of course if
you want to catch our full-length Reaction
watch along that is available for our super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page we cover
a whole bunch of stuff exclusively over there
and all you know reaction watches that you
need you know just that your support does
mean the world I really wanted to hop on here
to tell you that we have partnered up with
the channel geek that's g-i-q-u-e currently
I have an exclusive video over there koi has
two exclusive videos over there I do happen
to have a personal relationship with one of
the main people who's running it so yeah this
is something that is very meaningful to me
so what geek mainly does is provide these
one minute character origin stories and other
pop culture content from a wide variety of
creators I genuinely believe it's a wonderful
up and coming channel for a variety of reasons
one of them being not only is it a great place
to get some extra geek and nerdy content if
you you yourself are a Creator hoping to make
some extra bucks or get some exposure you
can join the geek community and possibly get
paid to produce a one minute short yourself
you can pause this video right now check out
one of our videos or you can just wait after
the reaction and go ahead and check it out
koi did An Origin story on Red Hood and Spider-Man
299 I did a very different type on Nightwing
but it really mean the world if you guys could
subscribe to them because over here at real
rejects we want to help get the spotlight
on them with what they're developing over
there I really do think it's a great communal
experience and something that is kind of necessitated
on a platform like this which can often feel
like more competitive instead of community
it's just a solid place to get some extra
nerdy content and to also help up and coming
creators absolutely thrilled to be partnering
with them now let's get on to watching Moana
[Music] a mother Island emerged art held the
greatest power ever known he could create
life itself this is cool
in time some began to seek if it is hard they
believed if they could possess it the great
power of creation would be theirs of course
he was a demigod of the Wind and Sea
he was a warrior a trickster and look how
good this looks
and his name was Maui Maui
but without her heart te fiti began to crumble
giving birth to a terrible Darkness
this is the one I I heard Dwayne Johnson this
is when doing Johnson plays right Maui tried
to escape but was confronted by another who
sought the heart holy God a demon of Earth
and fire wow
[Music] ooh chills guys whoa what an opening
magical fish and the Heart of te fiti were
lost to the Sea the Peril here the heart will
be found by someone who will Journey beyond
our reef and save us all ho ho ho thank you
mother that's enough there are no monsters
wow look at that animation my God so real
oh
how ethereal
foreign
do you have any comprehension of what's going
on right now [Music]
[Music]
there you are Moana what are you doing you
scared me [Music] dude sounds like Boba Fett
is it is it tomorrow worse it sounds like
him
wanna make way make way more night's time
you knew the village all you need oh this
is neat it's cool to see a movie about some
Pacific Islanders uh Polynesian culture
[Music] so adorable
[Music]
what we need what a great play on words there
I think I'm crazy or say that I drift too
far but once you know what you like well there
you are good Rhymes in here
[Music]
interesting it's like a journey about learning
to appreciate what you currently have while
also accepting that you want Adventure as
well as I am hooked I'm curious about that
chicken eating the rock I mean he seems to
lack the basic intelligence required for pretty
much everything
sometimes our strengths lie beneath the surface
oh my God
[Laughter] [Music] one room an old rule when
there were fish a rule that keeps us safe
instead of endangering our people so you can
run right back to the water oh he was you
he took a canoe morning he crossed the reef
he found an unforgiving sea his best friend
begged to be on that boat ah
[Music]
this one was making me want to sail
animal
s
delicious inspiring
[Music]
man I've really become a sensitive guy
[Music] I love hello guys so much so cute
there's more fish Beyond The Reef
damn this movie looks so beautiful I cannot
get over it not so bad
no
[Music]
ouch ouch
oh
[Music]
good thing those waters are clear she could
find a rock yeah this movie does a great job
on setting up the Peril I love this movie
what's in there the answer to the question
you keep asking yourself who are you meant
to be ban the drum and find Bang the Drum
[Music]
and Maui
I know really banging I put some rhythm in
there come on Moana foreign
what is happening right now
[Music]
is she seeing all this
oh my God you gotta go out there Moana
oh so beautiful so beautiful
oh that's your your true roots you're meant
to explore Moana when he stole from the mother
Island Darkness fell picker awoke to protect
our people the ancient Chiefs forbid for him
such a good lore building cool Universe one
day someone will Journey beyond our Reef
touristy you know what you gotta do Moana
the ocean chose you
uh-huh
the news we can take them fine Maui make him
restore the heart we were voyagers we can
Voyage again don't know how to introduce the
subject to you more
what grandma
oh you will board my boat sail across the
sea
the heart of this
I can't believe you oh this is so sad
[Music] Let Her Go
yeah I swear I do not come on here did you
cry Jesus Christ [Laughter]
sail Moana
[Music]
past the roof foreign
the chicken [Music] [Laughter]
[Music] yikes
I get a little help
oh not cool
this is a horror movie
wow appreciate that when it goes dark with
its visuals it really commits to it I said
how
not coming
fish peeing you all day Maui
Maui I am Moana of boat mode a boat the gods
have given me
Maui shapeshifter demigod of the Wind and
Sea I am one hero of men hero of men I interrupted
from the top hero of men go I'm here cause
you stole the heart of tefiti sail across
the sea and put it back that got stuck here
for a thousand years trying to get the heart
as a gift for you Mortals so you could have
the power to create life itself huh believe
you were trying to say is thank you thank
you you're welcome no no no I see what's happening
yeah know it's a lot the hair the bar what
can I say except you're welcome oh I've heard
some of this I think I've heard this song
before Oh this is where it's from
I don't think I ever paid attention to the
lyrics before
cool
that's our creative wow look at that that
is so great so much culture influencing here
[Laughter]
and thank you that is messed up
whoa you're a strong one Moana oh no no no
don't look at me like that it's a beautiful
cave she's gonna love it
[Music] ouch enjoy the island Maui hey you
have to put back the heart ocean help her
out you will restore the heart
all right I'm out
if you don't put it away bad things are going
to come for it Comfort this You Are Gonna
Get Us killed no I'm gonna get a city so so
you can put it back welcome what was that
kakamora Coco what murdering Little Pirates
what wonder what they're here for
oh my God they're kind of cute
thank you
holy crap I mean they're still kind of cute
you [Music]
[Music] this is wildly inventive
magic hook no magic power
that is awesome
no [Applause]
awesome they're just gonna kill you [Music]
coconuts
oh yes yes look at Rico
thank you foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
you got to go through a whole lotion of bad
not to mention tekka Lava Monster oh yes you'd
be a hero I am a hero me me were now you're
just just the guy who sold that is true put
this back save the world you'd beat everyone's
hero you're so smart Moana
the score and the musical numbers are so good
I called wayfinding Princess it's seeing where
you're going going in your mind knowing where
you are by knowing where you've been I'm not
a princess I'm the daughter of the chief considered
a Disney princess
you're measuring the Stars not giving the
sky a high five if the current's warm you're
going the right way [Music] wait Karma oh
gross gross
oh no this isn't real
come on oh my God they're getting Thanos
and he lives up there that's just the entrance
to um of monsters oh this is gonna be cool
damn the way they flesh out the environment
man like all the elements and stuff it's beautiful
hahaha go
oh how neat they're gonna go to talocon okay
let's get my hook
yo whoa what the hell oh my God that is scary
oh yeah
yeah realm of monsters indeed I hear why this
movie is PG now
[Music]
holy crap that was kind of scary [Music]
what have we here oh God they are funny looking
little things aren't you don't that's my grandma
there's my grandma I ate my grandma and it
took a week cause he was absolutely humongous
[Laughter] that's your main uh Clement I was
a tribe Little Crab once now I know I can
be happy as a clam because I'm beautiful baby
woman's neck just a sec don't you know Fisher
Dum Dums
beginners I love the direction of these musical
numbers
[Music] still a little rusty
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa
you so prepare your final play I love the
colors man
[Music]
damn that's great camera work in this the
heart you can't run from me oh you can you
keep surprising me where is it where is it
we gotta go what about the heart I think it
happened I've got a better one wait a minute
I see she's taking a barnacle and she's covered
it in bioluminescent algae [Laughter] [Music]
hey hey did you like the song I did I thought
the song was great you did me a solid but
you also almost died and I couldn't even beat
the dumb crab so chances of beating Taka bubkus
we're never making it to defeat you see you're
warmed up again man do you get your tattoos
they show up when I earn them what's that
for that's uh man's discovery of Nunya what's
nanya Nunya business oh I wasn't born a demigod
I had human parents took one look and and
decided they did not want me no I was found
by the Gods they gave me the hook and back
to the humans I went I gave them Islands fire
coconuts oh he's been searching for Love from
his parents his whole time huh maybe the gods
found you forever maybe the ocean brought
you to them because it saw someone who is
worthy of being saved you're damn right
hey that's cool they can Inspire each other
it's not my place to talk about female empowerment
but I feel like this is a pretty empowering
female character
look at you go Maui I think I'd be looking
for a curly-haired non-princess to start that
again that is literally the nicest thing you've
ever said to me probably should have saved
it for activity
just what leave you have officially delivered
Maui across the Great Sea
wow
you're like how horrified this is
water is its weakness we won't make it yes
we will turn around oh Moana stop
Jesus Maui
oh no Maui you have to restore the heart without
my hook I am nothing that's not true without
my hook I am nothing
sure nothing without the suit you shouldn't
have to suit at all I'm not killing myself
so you could prove you're something you're
not
chose wrong oh that's messed up
[Music] oh no the ocean's just gonna wait
the right tattoo is she dead they're from
voyagers who found their way across the world
they called me that's great it's a great story
of self-discovery man [Music]
yeah you are you little Voyager
go kick that thing zest whatever that
[Music]
is so cool I love this design
that's awesome using the Embrace of being
a Voyager [Music]
[Music] foreign
oh that's cool whoa oh you little badass that's
scary
[Music]
no what [Music] hey I got your back Chosen
One go save the world thank you this is so
cool I'm so happy right now [Music] oh smart
[Music]
man look how amazing that looks thank you
it's like some God of War [__] man
[Music]
oh wow use your last hit
whoa no
how
oh let her come to me
just chills everywhere right now laughs
[Music]
across the horizon to find you
this is so beautiful
oh it's just a torture
[Music]
you you know you who you are wow
what is this movie
oh my goodness
whoa this is this is insane whenever it releases
in the theaters I'm going
hmm the chicken lives I'm sorry about your
hook well I'm Maui what I did was wrong I'm
sorry
no way
that's cool he got to uh you gotta grow and
accept who he is before he even got that
huh this movie is beautiful absolutely beautiful
this would be such a cool video game you could
come with us you know my people are going
to need a master wayfinder they already have
one
goddamn right they do [Music]
hahaha
there goes anyway
God from beginning to end this animation's
been so striking it communicates so much emotion
[Music] it's kidding me man [Music]
I may have gone a little ways past the reef
it suits you [Music]
these are happy tears
foreign
[Music]
they're all voyaging look at them voyage
every sign
wow that was beautiful
dude dudes did this it's probably the most
surprising part of this
yeah it lines up pretty well actually uh yeah
that was a absolutely uh wait to see there's
a post-currency that's absolutely mesmerizing
movie I mean story about self-discovery exploring
different cultures like Polynesian culture
it wasn't like inspiring and uplifting and
and felt like and empowering as a 32 year
old man I was empowered by the Journey of
Moana and the story of acceptance of where
you are lineage and what you want to set out
to do as well it was just so gorgeous I really
respected it a lot you know I I like the Disney
I'm obviously playing some catch up here uh
in front of you guys on the channel but I
was always under the impression model like
just another Disney princess character but
she's so much she's like kind of not you know
it's like just because she's a female who
we categorize her as Disney princess but she
even says and here she blatantly States I'm
not a princess there's something that's so
strong and feels authentic and nuanced well
realized and lived in about her character
assertive determined flawed but uh strong
at the same time you know Wayne Johnson is
bow we also did an excellent job with his
performance it is timora Morrison okay is
this the second I heard of like sounds like
Boba Fett the way how Dwayne Johnson brought
this character to life because you know you
could feel a lot of that like chauvinistic
this almost veneer of machismo that this man
put on there was something that you could
feel this like pain underneath it all and
I like the fleshing out of the characters
this guy who really just wanted validation
and to be loved and connected with people
they managed to make him relatable like instead
of making him to relate to another Disney
character like a Gaston that wasn't him he
was someone who again was also flawed and
actually had well like good intentions but
made mistakes you know repercussions happen
but it was also such a character journey and
I love the dovetail of how both these individuals
while sort of Judge for being who they really
are aspects of them that are loved and accepted
but what I thought was cool about the movie
too with with these with their two titular
characters was that who they really were was
a part of them was not truly accepted by others
but they had to learn to accept that about
themselves first you know so it is a story
of self-discovery and self-acceptance it's
just a great message overall for people but
the songs too were so well done uh I I think
that you know you hear a little Manuel Miranda
in the crash like that lines up because I
was noticing like the Rhymes are really really
cool but it wasn't like rap heavy but there's
still some really cool Rhymes that they had
and I thought they had so much personality
and life and humor and it was also so moving
and sweeping and I kept saying it throughout
the the animation uh it had this great ethereal
quality that really fleshed out the tone and
this mood this atmosphere to life that I I
was so swept up in I found it so powerful
like the animation itself was was its character
it was a character in and of itself uh throughout
the whole film The Ocean while there was that
Motif with the the when the ocean pops up
to talk to Moana and sometimes carry her uh
back onto the canoe the ocean itself was a
character it breeds such life like this movie
had such fast rich life to it from beginning
to end with the culture uh influenced throughout
you know and I think like the different kinds
of creatures that we saw felt like something
out of like an epic PS5 video game to be the
way they handled the Peril and and at times
like the they needed some of that horror animation
to really strike a chord that way the the
more joyous light Parts uh really shine through
as well you know you need that balance and
I feel like sometimes these animated movies
you know more so with like the Disney animated
movies it can be a little bit timid now to
go down that realm so I appreciate it when
you did see like certain moments that were
like that is truly scary when they countered
it like with a taka character when they countered
it with seeing like when she's like beautiful
big and green and boisterous like and and
one with the nature you needed that effect
of like all the lava and the tortured Soul
like there was so much Humanity infused and
so much emotion there was like depth to the
designs of the characters even in the big
Larger than Life creatures like with the crab
guy it was so funny like that that's got to
be Jermaine Clement recognize his voice uh
with the crowd weather was there was so much
expression brought to life physically but
internally I really feel like the way they
went about with animating their characters
it was always rooted in some kind of emotional
core rather than just going we got to make
this look cool it was rooted in some way of
what is the best way to enhance the experience
of it on an emotional way where we can connect
to it because they did such a great job with
the eyes um but the body language too was
was something that I was really noticing in
this film like the body language of these
characters even the bigger creatures like
to call like them and the crab creature's
name but I like the crab teacher but even
even the little Pirates the body language
so well done shiny I'm so shiny didn't help
me though did it still upside down here just
need a little push [Laughter] can we be real
if my name was Sebastian and I had a cool
Jamaican accent it totally helped me you would
you know you would I was funny worth it sticking
around we're sticking around but anyway yeah
I mean I I love that the movie was also like
uh
like there's a story about like conquering
something like you know find Maui and and
and say this thing to to Maui when you find
him but you know like the whole goal is to
heal her Village and the problems that it's
encountering in the movies really about healing
and I I love that that the film is ultimately
about healing and when you get to the end
even with the car she doesn't try to strike
like you think it's leading to like striking
them down and defeating like oh you use the
water against the car really it's like the
objective that you have to do in order to
accomplish is to heal the villages you got
to heal to con I thought that was such a beautiful
message as well you know like the the way
to resolve is the path of compassion I think
there's a lot there's a lot of beautiful displays
of compassion throughout this entire movie
like she's a very compassionate character
and I love that about her I love the animals
a lot super like the the chicken was was the
MVP of the movie to me in so many ways that
the chicken was amazing I also noticed there's
no love interest in this film uh which is
actually refreshing we're really making or
not a Disney princess character like it's
a story just about friendship and family and
it seemed like it could have gone down this
route that could have been like kind of cliche
of like my family doesn't get me and I gotta
kind of go against what my family thinks about
me and do it and while there's a like a little
quality about that it it really is a a story
that feels respectful of towards your elders
you know and and I think she I think the movie
really nailed that as well like she is very
loving towards her family and so much so to
the point of bringing this movie full circle
with going to the lineage of the family being
voyagers and I love how that wraps around
and becomes this massive influence and someone
who's going to become the new Chief you got
to have this display of new kinds of leadership
abilities and ways of moving you know the
family forward and I I thought that was beautiful
aspect to the movie as well wrapping it around
full circle with the Voyager quality but also
you know being respectful and and connective
with the family as opposed to going down this
route of like she's a teenage girl and she's
going to rebel against her family they didn't
do that storyline like it never felt ingrained
in being a rebellious kid which is where I
thought the movie was setting it up to go
but it didn't quite do that it was just the
right it was just following her heart of what
she knew what was right and what was best
for her family so it was about again about
healing and learning about yourself along
the way and also learning uh you know a cool
skill with being a wayfinder uh I like that
in order for her to accomplish her goal she
really had to learn something along the way
like a physical set of skills and of course
being you know taught by Maui but I I also
really loved how that was put throughout like
it was it was a beat that was constantly being
explored throughout the movie because by the
time she she has to learn us I really don't
feel like when it comes to these Princess
Characters like she's not even a princess
but I really feel like when it comes to these
kind of characters they normally don't have
something like that and I think that was a
really cool objective that they put in front
of her so she's learning about herself she's
learning a physical skill I think there's
just a lot of great learning throughout it
and it feels like it's I imagine I'm curious
what the research was on this movie with everything
they wanted to infuse into here because there's
so many themes that are so beautiful throughout
but also it's like a tone poem happening with
its environment hitting you in the fields
throughout and just it's Landscapes and elements
that are so wonderfully woven in but yeah
guys I thought it was uh I thought it was
an amazing movie and I'm glad I watched it
and uh thank you guys for being here with
me on this journey I thought it was excellent
everything all around I thought it was an
excellent excellent movie so thank you be
sure to leave a like subscribe you can check
us on patreon and let's send this with a
caldorian dude it's good to see you again
how have you been I'm actually going to be
at this moment of this video going up I'm
in Colorado your home state right now getting
hitched so caldorian I haven't heard from
you in a while I hope everything is going
good and the Native American part of your
life and I want to say that the conversations
we've had in the past have been a wonderful
gift that's being Christmas and the time of
giving I want to say that you've gifted us
along the way with not just a wonderful pledge
but also uh with being vulnerable and sharing
so much about your life and who you are with
us and I know there's some tough bouts that
you had to go through but you've always been
someone with a after watching a movie that's
so much about compassion and love it's great
to know someone like you who is so full of
compassion so full of love so-called dorians
it's great to see your name up here again
but uh I hope that you're able to have a wonderful
Christmas and and have a fantastic celebration
for the holidays because there's anyone who
deserves it it's you you're so full of generosity
in your heart and in every way you communicate
even when you're stressed out or in a negative
or bad mood it's never to the point where
I feel like you're you know bringing me down
in any way because you you just have that
like loving caring quality always omitted
so thank you for being you and thank you for
being part of our patreon and thank you for
always being like one of our top supporters
buddy uh hope you have a Merry Christmas and
a Happy New Year and what are your plans for
the New Year let me know man I want to know
I want to know what crazy goals you got in
mind because you are an ambitious creative
fella and I want to see you knock some [__]
out so be well buddy thank you [Music]